what's happening there reject nation
greg and john back at it to watch the
boys episode five today that's right we
got mics now
yay hey there better audio yes all
righty well if you guys can leave a like
we'd very much appreciate that helps
design the algorithm and leave your
thoughts down below what you thought
about this episode also subscribe and
click that notification bell to get
notified when our reaction for episode
six is up is that i'm gonna be here
orgasm oh my god is that one thank you i
think that one was your guys is it this
one i don't know either way full length
watch alarms we sync up with the time
code for the boys over at our patreon
page for super sexy rejects at the same
tier you get the option for reaction
highlights and watch alongs included for
some other shows as well then boys at
prepper thank you for helping us out
these highlights and with the consistent
yellow dollar bill signs limit there's
no ads for the boys want to thank
athletic greens for sponsoring this
video genuinely like uh when we started
partnering up with athletic greens they
don't want me to say this i didn't just
say this for my own heart i've been
drinking them every single day for like
the past month and john's been drinking
one right now
uh yeah we genuinely really like your
stuff and also as you know two people
who have been having a crazy schedule
lately and not really sleeping much it's
been hard to get some exercise in
something that's really been helping
maintain some energy and focus maybe
it's placebo maybe it's authoritarians i
don't know it's been helping me feel
more energetic and i haven't been
bloated lately so yeah thank you
athletic greens
fire
forgot to wear my supernatural shirt dab
you greg
it's a radiation sulfuric acid cocktails
more or less
right up his arms
[Music]
i would watch that hbo series
gnarly the whole point
of what we do
the whole
god damn point is that no one should
have that kind of power well ain't that
just [ __ ] fairies and dancing dildos
hey i am to live right down here mate
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
what
no
kid brother feeling a little
responsibility
the greatest humility i accept your
nomination as ceo of vaught
international
okay ashley that's enough let's not
bring the room down apologies sir of
course hello everyone sorry i'm late
no power
with the changes around here our ebitda
margins will drop a tiny bit how do you
want to handle that on the earnings call
do you think you know better than me
oh you should be sitting in my chair and
i should be sitting all the way down
there in yours
oh god no sir
i'm so stupid and you're so great
maureen you're embarrassing yourself you
should go
justice for marine allow me to introduce
you to the new
head of crime
analytics the deep
[Music]
oh god
no
if you work hard enough there's nothing
you can't achieve hashtag dream big
because vaudel makes you the right man
sorry barbara right person gets the job
so to break the ice
[Music]
cupcakes cupcakes
from sprinkles enough for everybody
homelander killed alex he [ __ ]
murdered him
and it's all my fault hey
it is not your fault
come here come here
you guys could have been smarter about
it
let me take care of you for a second
tell me you found it
moscow was a dead end
i'm sorry
what
[ __ ]
don't lie man come on you know what i'm
gonna get you a white claw
would you like a fresca what uh part
you're most upset about is it the part
where uh soldier boy is loose in russia
or the part where i took some temporary
compound v it could be
both parts uh
all the parts
that's that's no secrets that's got to
be worth some points
kiwi man of the year
you could have gotten yourself killed we
don't have any more and even if we did i
wouldn't take it it was awful the
hangover
all of it just
absolutely hated it
yeah sure you did you loved it i [ __ ]
really loved it it was awesome i mean
you know me
that was stupid and dangerous i can't
lose you too oh god i'm sorry i'm sorry
you're right it's over
yeah okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
comrade soldier boy
god damn there better be a full-on
soldier boys that's pretty good
what are you gonna do with those
no thanks
i've been sober four months
[ __ ]
it's been a year for me
[Music]
no god damn it man you are such a toxic
influencer this is not going to go well
used to be mum so they've worked to tell
you how to suit gunpowder
not even the new york minute
it must have felt good
oh my god they're going to do it aren't
they they're going to do it all of it
does is just
all that [ __ ] that's already inside and
it's not just homelander i mean you
[ __ ] all got to go every [ __ ] lost
one of you yeah but they're bored into
this it's different than being an adult
who starts taking yeah it's thrust upon
you before you know what to do
oh
there we go
oh no
hero foreplay
i i i got this feeling in my bones
oh god nuclear erection time
[Music]
i did not think there were going to hear
what this season is nope
get it maeve
it was me
who came to you
made a deal with you take it up with him
i don't know him
i know you always who says you're the
one who pays the debt you work for me
now poor frenchie you author see me and
elvine's daughter katarina you do it
today
oh my god call me
money's done
oh you hot russian [ __ ]
did i say she's hot yeah i meant it
it's you it's you
how's it going
what happened
it was your point gosh
why does she have a smile is she not
super anymore
[Music]
let's run some human tests
[Laughter]
it's really dangerous that soldier can
do that
what an interesting way to
introduce that though congrats from
lindsey graham
homelander has agreed to a meeting with
you in blue hawk
okay great hi hey thanks for coming on
such short notice
hey train hey
oh no
i wanted to talk to you about your
patrols and training a little excessive
says who well a lot of black folks this
has nothing to do with
african americans
see what i did there and you don't want
people to say that you're being racist
right
you know it's actually
racist to call somebody racist
[Laughter]
make an apology or some [ __ ] what a
great idea
thank you for saying that maybe patrol
other neighborhoods
[Music]
bobby
bobby itch it
crazy tonight
oh you're not definitely not for that
that's a realistic take
next you'll tell me women have the right
to vote
[Music]
oh wow real winter soldier effector
[Music]
can't wait for them to interact
oh dude
maybe
the best way to handle this is to find
him i never thought of that obviously
god okay so why don't you go and do that
run along and save the day
tell me this isn't who i think it is
probably exactly what you think it is oh
my god
look we're coming on the site now can
your crime analytics people look for him
i'm on it just be careful haley
you should never have a conversations
right outside a homeland store i'm just
saying and without like other [ __ ]
playing like you were doing with
superstars
[Music]
damn look at that destruction
wow
didn't you break your arm yes it turns
out it's a bad sprain so i'm okay i'll
see you later okay
can't be leaving breadcrumbs like that
let's just focus on the job at end
let me help you with soulja boy
oh yeah that much and then you don't go
see me
okay
yes
have a little v on me
where is everyone we are everyone deep
fired mostly department what oh you
prick deep
rich
man
you should not be doing this man this is
a terrible idea oh this is so bad
is this what you wanted for me to use my
platform to help the community right
five minutes
oh dude a fight's gonna totally break
to the residents of trenton thank you
for giving me the opportunity
apologize if any of mine have been
perceived as being
racist but that is not who i am okay
just
ask my friends many of whom
are are black like a train
excellent
[Laughter]
and there's a sign of my commitment to
you all
what about what you did to raymond
tucker would you have done the same
thing to a white guy in mill hill
i go with the crimes and the crime just
happens to be
in black neighborhoods that's not my
fault oh you dumbass
oh dude
i was acting in self-defense
[Music]
black lives matter
walk away
all lives matter
[Laughter]
soup lives matter shut the [ __ ] up
oh yeah
yep yep oh
[Music]
oh you prick
true
no
i couldn't have seen that [ __ ] coming
man saint grubhub
[Music]
from stranger things to the boys i was
balls deep in golden giesha and
marlon brando was apparently balls deep
in me
what that's gay now
[ __ ] you who cares what's the difference
anyway after that
[Laughter]
legend soulja boy came to see you need
to know what he said what are you crazy
robin he's a [ __ ] doornail so who's
that coke for that's just me i'm writing
my memoir it's gonna be
really dynamites oh my god a soldier boy
in there you forget what happened last
time i helped the underage hooker sting
on electroshock oh
oh
hey there i thought i was staring at a
ghost
but it was him he hadn't aged the day
though it got a little fishy when he
started in that loving war picture with
phoebe cates he was 63 she was 19. oh
[ __ ] uh why was soulja boy here came to
pick up his super suit i'm sentimental
although i did actually wear the suit
once for kelly lebrock
this guy's
such a producer
big l big b the other
[Laughter]
letters he also came for his
girlfriend's address i didn't get the
feeling it was gonna be a happy reunion
but i don't know
maybe you can go there and find out
america is safe
okay it is safe so everyone get out
there go to your restaurants and uh go
to your movie theater
drink some bleach
eat a tide bud
you're out to get me aren't you what are
you talking about
it's smelling all over you oh my god
john come on
i'm not cooking anything up with butcher
let's talk about this oh she there
[ __ ] doing me
you could play this way smarter mate
yeah
you know the real tragic thing in all of
this was anything about us ever real
it's a good question actually
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
damn
it's like a flak noir phantom i hope you
got a almond joy up your sleeve up your
gauntlet i mean who do you guys want do
you guys want gawky weak
freaking the [ __ ] out huey or do you
want strong confident handling of [ __ ]
huey
oh my god this is way more
psychologically worse for huey what the
[ __ ] did he do to maeve that's all right
gregory maeve is at the global wellness
retreat in malibu asking for help uh
we can't let him do this who are you
referring to
i know you're scared
i am too but
this ceo job it can't be worth your life
oh my god homeland is right there
you don't need power take some v please
where is maeve
she even alive
[Music]
uh oh she's retreating i am ceo
a plus
real boss move
lacerations to vertebrae t6 t7 t8 and t9
the damage is so severe that nathan will
never walk again
you got to be kidding me you know to
think that my donation to this community
would be met with such intolerance
[Music]
just breaks it oh my god he's gonna
actually start genuinely caring yeah
it's not real until it comes to your
door
[Music]
i'm so worried french is going to die
this season i've got rhythm i got music
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
oh no
[Music]
[Laughter]
this is so wonderful and i'm so uneasy
there's a full musical number i know
[Music]
not bad love it
more
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
is
oh my my dude oh wow
so the first or second season he tried
kissing her and she really did not
[Music]
no
[Music]
[Laughter]
outbreak technically those aren't chimps
circumstances
suporn
he played himself in the last two
seasons he played himself again that he
is
exactly what seth rogens into
1950 per minute get that spandex down
start popping those things in there
whoa
your lover boy's on his way here soldier
boy
he's alive
how do you escape from russia
oh
she sold them out yeah yeah we're sure
hollisan will work
look that way in the reds video we knock
them out we keep them out then we figure
out what to do with them what the hell
is going on
mm-hmm oh no
oh amy what are you doing here mm called
me oh
you're probably gonna be mad
but i promise no more secrets right so
whoa oh my god
yikes
i'd know that crackle anywhere
[Music]
oh oh no oh butcher what'd you do
you serious man
my god he's back
[Music]
oh he cleaned up trim that beard you
want to counter says hit on a spunk
don't you
consider it a gesture of good faith good
faith for what i was thinking that you
and i have come to a little arrangement
oh my god
crossover it wasn't my idea
god you gotta believe me how much did
the russians pay you
they didn't
they didn't pay you anything
all those years
that they burned me pumped me for the
poison
i held on to the hope
that you would go
because i still loved you
i hated you
got bald countess
oh you just signed your deathwood man
let us handle this you can yell at me
damn
they really went far away to talk
i hope that mm got away
okay
he's had four or five legs everywhere no
you [ __ ] roofied him
i need you to fight homelander
team up
jurassic park
works on everything
[Music]
oh my god hugh is on the same page
already he's how we kill homelander and
newman maybe if anyone's strong enough
he is
you knew butcher was going to do this
never would have gone for it and you
look you weren't supposed to be here
this is so bad so bad i'm doing this for
you whatever it takes are you
remember whatever it takes you're
thinking
please don't go
[Music]
i mean i kind of get both sides though
you need something where i get so blind
or jesus
witness an awesome display of power
wow that was like just a straight up
drama episode yeah
with a musical number
wow
this really is darker season
next one will be so much fun
[Music]
so it's a little bit more soldier boy
every episode
the last one is gonna be a solo episode
one location only soldier boy
oh
[ __ ] hell my
this [ __ ] show
i doubt there's a post credit scene all
right let's talk about it let's talk
about that
all right well
before we talk about this episode before
we review it which i thought was another
great episode very somber this one
it's been more of a somber season
overall
a word from
today's sponsor
thank you to athletic greens for
partnering up with us once again no joke
when we first started partnering up with
them i wasn't as familiar with athletic
greens and for the past month in between
that time i had to move and there's been
a whole lot coming out so exercise and
sleep has been very much limited so
definitely needed something to maintain
energy to remain reasonably healthy
we've been having athletic greens every
single day for over a month now about
over a month yeah it's 100 true i feel
like it's made a total difference in my
life i fully attest to it uh ordered
some of our own as well on top of the
ones they already shipped to us so i'm
hoping that we can save partner with
them for as long as possible because i
really do feel like it's been a major
health influence in our lives john why
don't you go ahead and tell them what it
is that we've been taking absolutely
we've been taking their ag-1 formula
which is comprised of 75 high-quality
vitamins minerals superfoods adaptogens
probiotics and more and what's great
about it is it's an all-in-one formula
so it's way cheaper than trying to get
all those things individually and then
come up with some kind of regimen and it
definitely has us feeling sharper
especially on these more sleepless
nights it keeps us feeling relatively
physically clean and fresh as well yeah
sometimes i take it twice a day usually
first thing in the morning right when i
wake up on an empty stomach if i have an
opportunity to work out i'll mix it with
like half of a pre-workout and a lot of
times if i actually have like a bad meal
i will have it at night before i go to
bed and yeah i really do stand by this i
really believe in the product a lot so
yeah no we're not making all the funny
jokes that we usually make because yeah
we are mentally clear and alert right
now thanks to ag-1 in order to make
these claims but also the great thing
too is your subscription is less than
three dollars a day for athletic greens
and when you use our special link
athleticgreens.com
rejects you'll receive some free gifts
as well including a year's supply of
vitamin d which you know not everybody
gets as much sun as we do
here in la so take advantage of that for
sure so yeah thank you athletic greens
really stand by everything we just said
right now and happy to be partnering up
with you guys because it's it's been
very helpful thank you all right uh
we're where to kick it off with no boom
well i mean let's kick it off with it
let's talk about soldier boy i feel like
it's what everybody wants to to get to
yeah
yeah
god i just keep craving more gents and
apples i know [ __ ] they're really like
cocktails in the spring they are getting
to the point where i'm like
there better be like just so much
soldier
and it better not kill him off like you
better be coming back for the next
season because it's just been one build
up after another and it's getting me
like antsy for more
more of him like i can't even really
review the performance yet like i like
what jensen ackles is doing i like the
teases that we've been getting
i appreciated those subtle
little nods uh not no i don't know
references
but yeah
because i remember it uh
it's not steve trevor
wait yeah steve trevor
oh my god it's been a long day no steve
rogers is captain america steve trevor
is wonder woman yeah
and in one room in 84 that was a comment
that was a joke that was definitely
going around about like he's uh they're
all surprised by the amount of
conclusion and diversity in the streets
yeah yeah yeah
yeah all the updated sensibilities and
stuff yeah sorry like i did like they
actually included that little hint at
the kind of point of view this character
has interracial couples what because i
want them to push the boundaries but
especially with getting jensen ackles in
here knowing his relationship with eric
kripke from supernatural and you know
just coming off of the ending of
supernatural i want them to go really
bold
with you know putting him in here
um
because i i'm aware that it's going to
get like very sexual it's going to get
like extremely sexual
uh like i i i'm i'm already concerned
about
i know we're gonna
not gonna keep that video monetized but
a lot of trouble getting i just don't
want it to get taken off of youtube it
is
or just be one big blur
yeah i i want i just wanted to be able
to live on the channel so that i am
already a bit
nervous about that one but he's talked
about on seth meyer's show
like yeah there's gonna be some like
crazy sexual stuff that he his character
has to do um
but i want them to go really bold with
it because
yeah i'm not even i don't really have a
sense of yet who this character is other
than the the you know
carrying over like we haven't really
explored
who he is as a person yet like we're
still still yet to grasp um
you know what is his association with
the world was his personality going to
be like is he going to be more anti-hero
is going to be straight-up villain you
know how are they going to mesh all this
we all have our theories and predictions
of how this can go down especially for
those who've really dived into the the
source material
but i'm i'm still waiting for what is
the what is the portrayal because yeah
it's a lot of it is very much currently
just a big riff on captain america and
both winter soldier um a strong clash of
both of them
and you know but a more of a realistic
version of it all yeah yeah yeah so yeah
that ending scene you know because for
crimson countess his girlfriend because
they were saying like everyone hated you
you know she's saying that to him and
you know really believe that speech he
was giving when he was you know
lamenting that the sorrow of not
of feeling like he kept hoping you would
come to me and rescue me
but everyone hated him
and yet we didn't really we haven't seen
much of why why did everyone hate him
yeah and it's not a complaint it's just
i'm waiting for that before i can really
dive into like jets and apples is
performance yeah totally because they're
just giving you i i like right now i'm
really enjoying the pacing of the show
for those things getting yeah a little
bit we start to hear whispers about this
weapon something to do with soldier boy
we see a few flashbacks and then
increasingly we get just more glimpses
of who he is but i like that they've
kept most of his character as seen
through everybody else's eyes who knew
him who was there for the history
through mm and with him too like i
thought you know the way that they're
going about teaming up with soldier boy
potentially and also gearing up to maybe
have to deal with him as a physical
threat i thought the way they tied that
into everything with butcher and huey
and especially mm has been really nice
too and that gradual
you know pushing towards the edge
because i think you know it's i wouldn't
say it's like a completely foregone
conclusion but i like that in this
episode mm doesn't actually take the v
it's like i feel like it will happen
there will be that breaking point that
line that he will cross
but at the same time i like that here
you know you get those moments of
tension where you're like it looks like
he might be ready to snap and do it but
he's really trying to hold on to his
moral compass because that's what this
is all about and i think it's really
nice that they keep that in mind because
it's easy to lose yourself in the
fantasy and in
you know the darker implications of the
philosophy but i think that is the
trickiest one is like how do you defeat
such depraved enemies without becoming
depraved yourself and negating the whole
process well the this process is like
like it's just so not thought out on
what they're doing you know if you have
if you do ultimately have a weapon i
think it's going down a path where
soldier boy and
homelander i think in the comics they
slept together oh yeah let's see that i
don't want i don't think they're going
to do it for that whole hour i want that
yeah i i don't think they're going to do
that but i think they are going to form
a kinship i think they are going to form
a bond
and i feel like that's kind of what
they're alluding to sort of a
like that that when homelander was
watching him a bit of this
interest or desire or something i'm not
sure exactly what it was
but definitely a curiosity about him
that felt more than just a
like it's it's and then with the little
teasers we've gotten about
the kind of individual that soldier boy
is i would venture to guess that they're
probably going to form some type of bond
and it is not going to go according to
plan but i'm like even if it did go
according to plan
like
come on guys you're not thinking this
through if you did have this ultimate
human weapon who was able to take down
homelander but this guy's a horrible
dude how are you going to take down the
guy how are you going to take down the
thing takes on homeland or then yeah
yeah if you've ever played you've
literally just swapped your problem for
the same problem yeah yeah so um yeah i
that it just seems like one big
compounding problem after another
and an adventure to guess that mm that
like when that when this plan goes to
[ __ ] that mm would then have to take
some v24 to then try to take down
soldier boy but like i said i just don't
want them to get rid of soldier boy this
season if they do ultimately end up
killing him
but i do really like the darkness so far
of him like it's such like jensen ackles
is an amazing if you've seen
supernatural that's obviously the work
that most including ourselves are mainly
familiar with the guy in
um and where you got to see most of his
range and that show you do get a lot of
different ranges of that one portrayal
where you do see a lot of versatility
with that actor
and i'm like oh yeah no dead sandals toy
pull this roll off
uh but
yeah i mean they are doing a
like this this [ __ ] back and forth
thing with like huey and starlight
you know like first it's the
first season is huey is uh brina prete
is is falling in love with her but he's
working with the boys and you know she's
a part of the the seven the enemy
and then in the second season you know
like she doesn't really trust him and
they are you know
by the end of it they they end up
getting back together and here they're
filing together and now
these choices and i like the how they're
doing the v24
as a as as a drug analogy you know
getting hooked on drugs and using it as
a crutch you know it's like when it's
such a different conversation with
butcher who's kind of surrendering to
something
as an extension to take down things but
he already displays confidence here he
displays strength he he's already proven
himself where he can he can handle
certain [ __ ] now he's just using this
whereas huey is like i am a completely
different human being and i like that
person i can i i feel like i'm actually
i can contribute something physically to
the team finally
you know and so it's it's a very
different psychological relationship
with v24 versus what butcher has and i
think it's cool that they're able to
draw both
like two different dynamics with
uh taking the drug
um you know in a way that doesn't feel
like repetitive or just watching two
characters go through the same thing
um with the with the same vice or the
same crutch i i think that's really neat
how they're
um
uh drawing that and uh
it was heartbreaking at that end you
know it didn't feel like just another
repetitive
uh come on of course they're together
now they're not going to be together
thing it's like uh huey
he keeps saying he's doing this for
starlight but it's there's more than
that that he's doing it for because of
how it makes him feel as a as an
individual
and
you know as someone who's always trying
to teeter on because because since
season one
they've teased huey just eventually
getting to a breaking point of pure
darkness
and you know it brings it back to that
because huey really was the main
character of of the first season
and um
like at least i thought so and you know
it seemed like it was all drawn from his
perspective for the most part and
now it's sort of bringing it back to
that trajectory of what's going on with
that character too and i think jack
white's doing an amazing job yeah no
totally and i'm
i mean it already there was that theme
brought up in the mave scene about you
know it's all this stuff drugs whatever
else v24 it all just makes you more of
you it just amplifies what's already in
there and i know that there's that
aspect of huey was like no i'm a totally
different guy but you do get that hint
at the end of we're right back here to
you using this no more lies thing to
just cover up a bigger set of omitted
truths yeah and so what more
from the things that huey is trying to
run away from are going to make it into
his uh you know personality and
physicality as he goes further and
further down the v24 rabbit hole and i
mean yeah like that's a plotline that
could easily become like oh come on you
know like wheel spinning and wrote but
it feels like yeah there's just given
this world that we live in and
starlight's position and huey's position
especially you know as inter
abilities you know couple it seems like
there's a natural order in which it
would be hard for them to ever have a
happy relationship and uh and yeah i
appreciated that quite a bit and uh i
mean
god this was not a very like
homelander-centric episode i did enjoy
like the little bits of him
this is almost the episode where he was
like too distracted with learning how to
run vaught and being like oh god this is
a lot for for this is more than i
bargained for kind of um
but you know even so i thought they made
his moments very still like impactful
each time he was there that whole thing
with maeve is is
nasty
and chilling well being able to smell
butcher on her i mean the way she tried
lying her way out of it
oh you're being pretty obvious me yeah i
think i think as an actor it was kind of
an intentional choice because i think
the way she was playing start collecting
for me halfway through the scene because
at first i'm like oh my god bad lying
but i i it started i'm not just saying
this to be
kind it it did strike me as i know i
think the scene was played intentionally
like bad line because it was more of a
demonstration
she had to be doing bad lying because to
get to the point where you're divulging
the whole truth that even when we were
like dating and and sleeping with each
other i had hated you since day one and
i have feared you since day one so to
get to the point of letting that go it's
like the lying had to be bad as a sign
of she's not even trying her best to
cover this up yeah like she wants to
yeah that's a good point i mean it felt
very like cliche horror music got me as
a jump scare it was like still kind of
like goofy when i look back i'm like
black no orange
yeah
yeah with the bag it's a little goofy
but it's looking at me yeah at the jump
scare moment yeah but i thought
it did sell me like i think what they've
done so well with the season is
uh
more than the other ones is a homelander
could just kill anyone at any time now
he always had that ability but now it
just seems like he there's like nothing
and no one to stop this guy at any given
moment not even ashley no
not even
not even oh god and all this stuff with
a train this episode was gnarly
there are parts of the writing of it
though where i did
i have no issue at all with them uh
infusing like political stuff uh it's
never been a i've never been like [ __ ]
up and i've never had an issue with that
i do think some of it is is a little
too overt like
i mean i mean i feel like still do it
like i'm like yeah you can still do
black lives matter all lives matter
cancel culture like you can totally
still do all that
i i
might this is a subjective taste i
personally prefer it when it's a little
bit more like you're replacing words
instead to not make it as obvious you
know like i preferred it when he was
saying soups lives matter
versus like immediately going black
lives matter all lives matter like okay
now you're not even
you know you're just so direct about it
yeah like okay so in the world of the
boys all these movements have also been
happening
totally where i liked it better when
they are doing a commentary on it as
opposed to just let's just pluck it out
and put it here yeah it's like i do like
the the the way this show i've i've
heard some reviews com
kind of liking it to being less of like
a satirical commentary world and more
like a mirror world to ours that just
happens to have soups and so yeah this i
feel like they do a good job generally
of writing a fine line of going that's
the language that i hear for these
conversations in real life but yeah
packaged up in a way where it doesn't
glare out and i feel like yeah while i
appreciate the intention of especially
that
scene as that speech goes down as the
fight breaks out it is one of the few
times where the yeah it's like you said
the overtness kind of does pierce
through the artifice and then you're
like oh
i can kind of feel like bullet points of
the sentiment for this scene rather than
it feeling like
i almost feel like that scene could have
used just a little bit more breathing
room to get us there so that you can
finesse that stuff because you're
getting the you're showing it you're
getting the point across yeah without
needing to be so on that you don't need
to call it antifa and all these like i
would i would have picked up on like
yeah they're commenting on antifa
without it's like they're at the point
now where like you might as well call
this trumpism with homelanders you know
yeah but i'm like i already pick up on
it without you having to say it you know
yeah yeah um
and especially with homeland or stuff
like a lot of that you know is so
trumpian yeah
and he uses a similar language but yeah
it's not like exactly just coming out
and saying it's this
and i mean i'll give you i feel like you
know you can get a black lives matter or
one of the actual world catch uh slogans
or or repeat phrases or mantras or
motifs in there but when you start to
kind of get a tops game of them going it
does feel like you are aiming for those
you know uh you're aiming to kind of
break the wall with those and sometimes
that again subjective taste and
sometimes
that will pull me out to the point where
i feel like the
the point and impact of
what they're trying to convey actually
is not as strong because i'm being now
now i feel like i'm being told it and
i'm like i already get it you know well
yeah we've already heard this language
for the past few years
yeah and one thing that's great about
the sensibility of this show is i feel
like while the politics are on display
surely and that must take a certain
amount of people off i can't i can
imagine that there's probably a
percentage because of how edgy and harsh
the show is and because it shows
multiple perspectives on multiple
aspects of life it's like i could see
people watching it who maybe don't share
certain beliefs that are motivating some
of the writing and that scene was one
where i was like
i would imagine a lesser amount of
people
uh sort of just being in the rhythm of
the show and then not getting pulled out
by that like people who could benefit
from that message and who maybe could
you know uh uh this is coming from
people who don't totally lean towards
these political beliefs yeah it's like
us in that scene with with blue falcon
or whatever his name is like you're
preaching to the choir a little bit of
course we are on the side of a train's
brother basically like hey do this the
right way for christ's sake um but yeah
it's like i could see somebody who is
not on board with black lives matter
watching this and in certain instances
of that kind of commentary just
accepting it as part of the show and not
re not having that knee-jerk reaction
that you would to a more overtly laid
out here is a message you know and i
feel like that's a scene that might miss
that opportunity to hook somebody who
isn't on the page
with you know this who isn't part of the
choir being preached too yeah you know i
think season two had a great handle on
that and uh and for the most part this
one does too oh this season yeah it's
really just you know it's it might sound
like it's nitpicking but i i i don't
know to me it really would be like hey
come on you guys uh i've seen you be
insanely good and clever at this for a
long time yeah for like many episodes
now like 20 something episodes uh that
that that would kind of pull me out but
the context of what they're doing with
slowly watching a train you know kind of
this thing of
will he uh be a better person like he
seemed grow his soul because he's he's
constantly been in turmoil and conflict
over all the decisions we've seen him go
through even ever since the first season
starting off as a complete closed-off
cold-hearted [ __ ] who killed robin
to
now where he's at in his life you know
he even seems in conflict about turning
in supersonic and being kind of ca i
mean cowardice about the whole situation
um even this situation with um
yeah with the black community um uh i
forget what hometown their hometown oh
god it's uh
it's on the tip of my tongue too he said
it um
but yeah whatever that that community is
yeah and um
you know what and it becomes personal
for him too and his brothers and now uh
in the hospital and paralyzed is now in
a similar situation but he has no
superpowers that atran's been in before
where he can't where he's injured and
can't really move he's a little immobile
uh i like i like the context of that a
lot of watching as a guy who starts off
as i'm just doing this to to play kate
and to rebrand myself and my image to oh
there's more personal things that are
making him actually care more
in a in a in a more real way he's
realizing that the system of corporate
uh uh of of like corporate virtue
signaling doesn't actually help or get
things done and you can't come from that
place as he has been and expect to enact
real meaningful change on people's lives
yeah yeah i appreciate the context and
then frenchie and kimiko oh
like kimiko being excited about being
human you know they set her up with
being someone who
because she's always been kind of like a
good secret weapon for the boys you know
uh is this
but they've really established and
they've really dumped into a more that
she hates the fact that she is this
thing
and you know this this joy at being
human and i mean it's kind of like kind
of liking it to like when professor x
and days of future past starts like
loses his ab his abilities he can walk
yeah and she's like slowly getting her
voice back and then they the
expressionate way of showing her
emotions to the the music
her bonding with frenchie and
all this i feel i really am concerned
that like it's at the point where i'm
like oh man they could kill a frenchie
i'm still just having that tragic ending
yeah i'm constantly worried for frenchie
and kimiko's safety and well-being and i
i think they're drawing that story up
really nicely because i feel like
there's stakes for both of them
obviously it's like it's great for
kimiko to finally be human but also that
means she's way more vulnerable than she
was before and frenchie i mean yeah he's
caught i like his story of being caught
between these alphas and trying to break
out of that loop in that cycle and uh
and yeah i i hope to god they don't kill
him
i almost feel like that might be the
kind of dance that these characters have
to play sort of as a motif as they go i
like frenchie's story a lot in some ways
he's like the jesse pinkman of the group
um
he's he's such a such a sweetheart of a
guy like such a sweetheart of a guy
who's just made some terrible decisions
along the way he's gone on some terrible
paths and done some bad things but he's
really at his core um just as just a
really sweet human being
and and and then you know watching him
be tugged around here
when i'm like goddamn yeah butcher you
[ __ ] caught him in this [ __ ]
situation now and now he's now he's
suffering for it
um and i don't know maybe kimiko is
going to sacrifice her this part of her
that needs to be human and or like try
to get back her powers in order to say
frenchie in some way
um so now she'll be on the v24 too yeah
maybe something to ignite it uh yeah i'm
liking i'm i still like this one a lot
it's not exactly the most like i was so
shocked that chemical started talking
like that was the most exciting part to
me was like what
he's talking about
yeah and great music like i've never
even seen the i don't i've never even
seen the actress i'm assuming she can
speak and she or is she actually a
hearing impaired i don't know
um i've never seen any interviews with
her so i have no idea if she's hearing
compared or actually speaks um
but
yeah or yeah i mean or yes i mean she
can't be a mute i don't think for for
real i don't know if that's the correct
term i don't know the terminology i
don't want to offend anyone either way
yeah i'm trying but you guys know what
i'm getting in and sorry if i my choice
of words there was not correct
um
yeah
still i've never seen any neighbors
either so i don't know yeah yeah and i
mean that's kind of neat because yeah
because then she could just exist fully
in the characters
yeah she's just purely just chemical to
me and there's i mean so much great body
language between them to always like i
love
even though there is dialogue in the
sign language like i love
things like that where you really get
your performers just emoting physically
you know yeah very true in the deep
rising up
clearing out the research team what a
[ __ ] she's going to mess everything up
when he's at herogasm and she's on his
wife oh oh he is yeah oh and then she's
going to get with homelander
i mean she's controlling everything i
love all you cut to her she's he's just
reciting what she wrote yeah
oh
so cringey ass [ __ ]
um
chase crawford is so good in that role
he is like so good at that role he you
gotta give respect because he really is
willing to just come in with with no
dignity
he's the least cool guy
he really feels like somebody's kid
brother is just trying bending over
backwards to be cool and accepted he
exists to be like a punchline yeah and
uh
and yet he brings such humanity to the
character i think chase crawford's work
on it is actually pretty underrated he's
he's really great in this yeah
um
you got to be game like a really big
game he's playing this game exists to be
pathetic yeah and he just had to find
new lows like chase crawford is like a
really dashingly good looking dude and
like a very like physically fit guy yeah
he has the the natural looks of a guy
who could be a superhero um but i love
how he just plays it as such a pathetic
human being yeah
he's so good in the role
yeah so good yeah totally uh so yeah i
mean overall really somber [ __ ] uh this
is probably like the one with the least
exciting stuff in it and paul reiser
holy [ __ ] paul riser showing up in here
yeah yeah yeah paul ryzer and russia two
things very much tear it over yeah
carried over from stranger things it's
pretty nuts to see like the similarities
yeah and r.i.p lori holden goodbye
crimson countess i actually thought she
would last a little longer than
these couple appearances i mean i like
paul reiser's performance a lot it felt
like a commentary and like that not
exactly like a harvey weinstein but it's
like a [ __ ] music entertainment
producer yeah
big mogul of entertainment yeah yeah
he's maybe retired now but still very
much about that life yeah he's got that
layer of slime on him yeah so so
naturally he's uh he's just uh a few
rewrites away from being a guy in like a
a robe with a bunch of curly hair vegan
elliott
yeah yeah right you're right on the
brink of being that
um but yeah guys what do you think about
this episode leave your thoughts down
below thank you athletic greetings for
sponsoring this video yeah and last but
not least to a patreon
eric
if there's anyone at this patreon
i want to see in this world it's you
because you know why we got a herogasm
on the horizon and if anybody deserves a
lifetime pass to an event called
herogasm it would be you my friend
because think about the things we've
seen already in this show think about
the toys and instruments that were used
nearly an episode ago i want to see you
with that star spangled strap on my
friend i want to see you in some super
chaps you know compound or or v24 and up
you know what super imagine the super
powers eric horstmann would have he
could probably like break things in half
just by clenching his butt cheeks or
something like that you know i think you
are the perfect person to
descend not ascend but descend to the
depths of depravity but also do it with
the utmost style and the utmost
enthusiasm to the point where it looks
like a good idea that we would want to
try yeah it's not but it would look good
on you and that's why it's your day
buddy you're the man you're the man
let's oil ourselves up and uh
lose track of where who begins
[Music]